e
delandro is that what's happening on the
Senate side I just saw his name yeah his
name's on it right there Senator F
today not explain everything good
morning everybody
um this is the higher education study
committee and we're tasked for looking
at uh uh the higher education
institutions community college system
and the university system here in New
Hampshire and so starting out with today
I'd like to have our everybody on the
committee introduce themselves to the
public um this committee um
has a number of folks several people are
not here today and I'll start on the far
right hand side represent Mooney has a
doctor's appointment she said she would
be here a little bit later and so she
will be attending today and then I will
start with representa Hall who is
replacing represent Myer standing in for
representative Myer on the committee at
this time is that
correct big shoes to fill yeah I think
represent I represent Bo and hopkington
thank you Mr chair Dave luno serving the
education committee also represent Bowen
hopkington thank and I understand Hopkin
is really having some issues with their
property taxes with the assessment
values going up significantly so we're
seeing this uh obviously in places all
across the state and hopkinton's um
overall valuation went up by 78% so if
your um property was valued at more than
78% then your taxes go up less than 78%
then your taxes go down but I think this
is a byproduct of uh of a um you know
coming out of covid and U and with lots
of weird things sort of um you know
happening in the real estate industry I
don't think anybody would call this a
normal Market yeah yeah absolutely
Senator
Ward thank you Mr chair Ruth wart Senate
District 8 which goes from dun Barton
over to the River Connecticut River that
is so
and I'm Rick lad I come from havil I
chair education here in the state and
also in hail we our property taxes have
gone been assessed at 80% higher than
they were it's cost a
firestorm and of course we also have to
rely upon the Department of Revenue
Administration in terms of the equalized
ratios to see where we stand on that but
uh it's happening throughout the state
and the market is crazy right now so
there's a lot of issu is going on there
to my left we will have sitting there
representative delandro he will be here
a little bit later he is is
Administrative Assistant came in this
morning said he will he will be here and
Senator Fenton um uh is not here due to
uh a medical issue at at his home and
who is the farthest one over the oh
represent Ford yeah representative Ford
is uh on the committee still uh but he
is is absent today
and we have Steve applebe uh sitting
with us I asked Steve to sit here with
us seeing that he has also shared the
task force which looked at the alignment
of the
strategies uh for the community college
system and the university system and put
the report out that's already got all of
us hopping and moving forward so Steve
do you have anything to say about
that just no because there's a group of
people over there will probably tiar and
feather me so uh no I don't just uh
happy to be here in support however I
can we met for about three months and
was well close about 60 hours worth of
time we put into that with the I think
about 12 people on that task force a lot
of work a lot of effort and I think the
product is is one that's worthy and and
um tying it in with hp1
1450 uh I think we're making some good
Headway so we have in front of us today
several pieces the paper which uh for
those in the public don't have copy
there's copies over on the side there we
have an agenda and there's also
supportive information uh which came out
of the task force and it's not the whole
task force report it only has attached
to it the short-term and long-term
recommendations which came out of that
uh task force which there are a number
of
recommendations and we will get into
that some of the discussion on all that
today and I'd like to welcome the two
chancellors from the community college
system and the university system Kathy
preventure and Mark Rubenstein you're
you're both welcome you the hot seat is
available for you right here because you
might as well move up right now because
um we're going to be quickly getting
into that part of the the docket
today just as an
overview um the governor's executive
order that's
20236 and HB
1450 had some very specific uh issues
which we were asked to address and I'll
just go over that they're in the agenda
under uh item 2 a one or I public high
education strategy alignment one to
increase education attainment
opportunities to meet Workforce needs
that was one of those goals improve
accessibility and compatibility for New
Hampshire students so we really want to
look at this issue of access of all of
our students in the state to higher
education three minimize duplication of
academic programs appro as appropriate
appropriate while optimizing access to
students so if there's duplication of
programs going on if that there can be
some ISS uh changes made uh that could
be a changing uh uh Savings of of
dollars however we won't don't we we
need to be cautious that we are
optimizing and not taking the access of
these programs away from students for
example isolated locations so it's it's
an issue which we have to carefully look
at number four create potential for
economies of scale and Synergy if we
work together we're going to accomplish
a whole lot more so with the community
college system University system working
closely together um I think we can
accomplish many of those uh
recommendations and goals set forth in
their report and I'd like to recognize
senator delandre who just walked in
thank you very much Sor for my tied sir
you're not we're just started so welcome
thank
you do you have anything you like to
we've all had a chance to say a little
bit would you like to say anything
Senator
delandro okay speech is silver but
silence is golden great okay the sixth
um uh our fifth uh goal which was in the
report 1450 and which the task force Lo
is to enhance regional growth and
development six streamline and
administrative costs and obligations I
think we'll hear something about that
today for sure and number seven continue
to work towards transfer a program and
credit across the two systems and that
hearkens back to HB 1530 which we have
passed several years ago to try to have
transferability and Pathways established
between the Community College system to
the four-year
system with that I'd also like to
recognize director
applebe uh who was in chair of that task
force and Steve is sitting at the table
with us right now uh that report was
issued this this year in March 27 2024
it says 324 I don't think that's
possible but
2024 and that report is available online
and we do have uh a bit of it available
for the public as I've said uh in the
reports
uh Mr appy would you like to say
anything about that study committee and
what it
accomplished just to give us some
groundwork yeah thank you chair lad um
and I'm not sure what yourself and
representative luno have been doing with
your Fridays since that ended I know
that it was the highlight of your week
all through the winter um no thank you
to both of you and thank you to the
chancellors who gave their time um in
that effort really generously I mean we
we spent a lot of time talked a lot
about a lot of a lot of different
possible ideas um and hopefully the
synthesis to a set of shortterm and a
set of longer term goals um made it a
little more manageable for the systems
and I noted in the in the first filing
there were a number of items um that
they're already working on which is
wonderful or already have completed so
and I look forward to to talking more
about that so thank you very much and
item three underneath the new business
is I put this in here because some might
ask why is the study committee
representative Mooney you you're welcome
to sit over here to the
right you must have sped down that road
to get
here okay uh item three reads the
chancellors of the University system of
New Hampshire and Community College
system of New Hampshire shall submit
joint quarterly progress reports
addressing higher education strategic
alignment outcomes to the public higher
education study committee beginning with
the calendar quarter ending June 30 2024
or as requested by the committee that's
in law right now and that's why we are
meeting today to have that first
quarterly report presented to this body
beginning November 1 2024 and each
November 1 thereafter the chancellor
shall submit and annual report regarding
implementation of comprehensive higher
education alignment strategies and
findings to the governor and Council
Senate finance and education committees
the house finance and policy committees
the Board of Trustees of the University
system of New Hampshire and the
community college system of New
Hampshire and the commissioner of
education so this is a real important uh
uh issue which is moving forward and I
can recall that when I talked to Fred
Coker at WMUR he said this is probably
one of the most important issues in
higher education that he seen in this
lifetime and there's a lot of potential
that we're looking at here because our
our our systems were going through this
shrinking demographic of students and
the availability of dollars uh may not
be matching those demographic shifts so
with that I'd like to welcome
chancellors Kathy prenter and Mark
Rubenstein sign and could you please
take us through the report that you've
issued and uh under uh two be here uh
presenting that report I I noticed that
there's uh about seven or eight items
that you'd like to really speak to
so I'll leave it to
you thank you Mr chair um good morning
we're very pleased to present what we've
been doing since the report was issued
um for the record my name is Katherine
preventure I serve as the chancellor of
our state university
system um maybe we could just start with
a little bit of background to talk about
what we actually as soon as the report
was issued in I think the end of March
um Chancellor Rubenstein and I met with
um leaders from both systems to try to
digest the report because it is sweeping
and we can't tackle everything at once
so there's a little graph as in an
appendix to this first report that we
submitted to the committee and we we
identified a number of initiatives that
we were already jointly working
on but maybe not with the intention that
um was deserved and so we I think the
six or seven that are in your the first
quarterly report or there eight um these
are on goinging initiatives there are
others um but but and we can speak to
these and there's there are even some
updates since since this report and
while I have the floor the November 1st
report um I I'm thinking we're in all
likelihood maybe just going to give an
update to the items that are in this
report or if any others um any other
initiatives come on the docket but both
systems have a lot going on and so we
are we're not going to submit a Our
intention is not to submit a report
addressing all the short-term and all
the long-term recommendations rather
those we've identified as we're going to
start here we're going to get some wind
in our sales and continue moving moving
forward does that make sense to the
committee that that to me that makes
sense uh because we're talking about one
month from today exactly and um this has
happened very quickly and and looking at
this report right here I know there's a
number of short-term goals and longer
term
recommendations and you really have had
to sort of initially here pick out
certain issues that you can address
right now and others which are more
long-term need a lot of work I get it
and so it'd be really great if you could
for example start on page two of that
report with item number one which deals
with the how we're where we are in terms
of approving ability to transfer from
community college system to the
university system New Hampshire that's
number one right there that you've opted
to address in this report um then I I
think we can close out this thing at
least from my perspective and looking at
some of those other goals or incent
initiatives that we have there which are
important due to the issues surrounding
the state right now in terms of higher
education just article in the Wall
Street Journal just several days ago
that we know we have a number of our
high school kids which graduate from
schools in New Hampshire that opt to go
outside uh by outside to another state
within New England or further but the
Wall Street Journal came forward and
said this is no longer just a New
Hampshire problem it's a New England
issue that there's many students up here
now are opting to go to the southern
states like a Georgia Tech or a UNC
due to costs affordability and program
that maybe best fits their needs right
now all those various needs so we're
losing students to other locations
regions in this country today due to the
affordability the private school at
$77,000 a year is just Out Of Reach now
and so let's start off with number one
and then work towards some of those
other issues uh throughout the report
here and then talk about those La that
last
part recommendations for where we're
going for at least 25 years the issue of
transferability between the two systems
has been a conversation between the two
systems and also with the legislature
and other
stakeholders and I would tell you in the
last several years we've seen real
progress particularly catalyzed by House
Bill
1530 we now have very tangible uh I
think we're approaching 100 Pathways the
original deliverable was was 50 which
exceeded the request of Statute but at
at this point roughly 100 programs that
have been identified where students who
follow pathways through the community
college system can move seamlessly into
the university system and the thought is
that that has long-term benefits for
students not having to repeat courses
not having the frustration of
uncertainty and over time as we
Implement some new tools to be able to
help students m their degree progress
between the two systems to see how
courses and programs at our CCS nature
institutions will flow into the
university system we're going to make
that much easier later on I'll come back
to talk about Early College because the
ability to help anchor students
opportunities and interest while they're
still in high school here in New
Hampshire I think has long-term benefit
for keeping more of those students here
in New Hampshire making what might
appeal appear as appealing options to
the South or other states perhaps Le
less appealing less compelling when the
students have already made significant
progress and they and their families
have had significant benefit on the
enrollment I'd like to um I agree with
everything Jen
Rubenstein um shared I I do want to
point out a couple things um there's
technology needed to
make this really seamless and
userfriendly for this for our students
both community college and university
system so we're starting to Pilot some
of that um but it it's not as simple you
know because here's your
pathway these are the courses you need
to take
to come to the university system and get
a bachelor's degree in whatever your one
of the hundred um
Pathways but with techn techology that
faculty could keep up to dat as
curriculum changes over time and that
would help the students um be able to
interact with their Pathways and as they
choose different things or stop out and
come back so um that that that will be
an issue right we can make all these
Pathways but the technology will be
important and there's a CA to that
Chancellor can you speak to this a
little bit in the report which we got
July 2
2024 uh that came in from Wayne Jones I
believe uh the final report summary for
1530 had uh an area which dealt with
ongoing activities and it says advise
advisor training and Pathways
particularly for community college
system New Hampshire advisors is now a
top priority while both University
system and the community college system
are working toward full implementation
of tests the trans transer equivalency
system a common database of course
equivalencies necessary to help students
understand Pathways and customize their
Journey we are still working with
Pathways in PDF format manual advising
on navigating the course equivalencies
manual updating of courses equivalencies
and Pathways so how's this how's this
moving in terms of a student that's
going to be let's say at White Mountain
and wanting to go off into the fouryear
system knowing that the course I'm
taking is going to be a transferable is
there can they access this database or
is are advisors helping them right now
advisors are helping them right now but
what we don't yet have fully implemented
is the transfer database and the
transfer pathways through a separate
program so a lot of this is still very
labor intensive and it requires students
and advisors working closely together
you you may be happy to know that advis
users gathered at nhti conquer Community
College within the last two weeks for a
training session on this very topic to
try and make sure that we've got broader
awareness and understanding of what the
opportunities are for students across
each of the campuses But ultimately you
know that this generation in particular
is more likely to pick up their phone
than to text than they are to call or
ask a question so to the extent that we
can enable the technology and give
students the tools that are available
when they're ready to ask the question
of the technology and not speak with an
advisor we will undoubtedly make this
work better for
them other questions represent
luno thanks very much Mr chair and
thanks very much for uh for uh taking
the time to uh to talk with us about
this this morning um for a for a student
who has successfully completed a a
pathway through the community college
system and is ready to go about a
transferred to the university system
what's the admissions process uh like
for that
student believe that's a direct admit
that's what you that's what we're
working
toward that's well if they're in the
pathways this this was a separate the
the advising is likely going hand inand
on the pathways versus well what I'm
what I'm really what I'm really getting
at is um is um let's say let's say the
student started out at
nhti and um uh in an in an open
admissions is that the term um you know
a program that doesn't require any any
um U additional you know
um work uh but and and that student
successfully completes the pathway
whether that's an associates degree or
whether it's some some other certificate
program but is there for um has met the
requirements for for transfering to the
university system do they have to any
additional admissions or sat tests or
anything like that no no SAT test but
this is the process that we're working
on for direct admission to make this
more seamless that a student completing
that associate degree program is
directly admitted into the
usnh pathway that extends from the
associate degree toward a bachelor's
degree right now there's still an
application process and what we're
currently working on between the two
systems is a directed admission program
that would allow that student no
application fee simplified and there
there still needs to be some
communication from the student to let
them to let the US nature in institution
know who they are where they're headed
which institution which program but we
are trying to make that much simpler for
students and remove what has been a
bureaucratic uh step that students need
to take great great I I that's that's
wonderful to hear because I think that's
that's you know important for the
students I think it's important for the
families um as well to be able to see
that that that path exists for that
student from the first day they step on
the nhti campus uh uh that uh that you
know following successful completion uh
they'll be able to continue seamlessly
right through the university system and
I think um um more than a decade ago I
think we implemented a program like that
with uh the engineering technology
program in partnership with un
Manchester and um and
nhti and in fact on the the day they
started at nhti they were also
considered to be UNH students and um um
so uh so I'm really glad to hear that
that that approach uh uh can be extended
to so many other
programs another
um more intangible benefit of all of
this work is that folks from the
University system and the community
college system are working in Tandem and
are in constant contact UM the
enrollment people the the um advising
the even the communications people are
the Provost from the University system
and the vice presidents of academic
Affairs at the all the community
colleges are
meeting together quarterly so you know
it builds trust it it it really um is
providing a closer connection between
the two systems just just this one piece
of work
that's I actually mentioned the question
that we've just been addressing is
actually represented by reflected in
item two in the report we submitted that
describes direct admission a process by
which students who are completing
programs would flow seamlessly into the
the next program within the university
system that's great thank you very much
and would you like to move on to number
two no I'd like to one more question of
you what are the costs associated with
Tess in terms of to have this program
the software package in place which
seems to me to be a key to it being
successful as far as transferability for
our student so there are actually two
component programs and I won't get into
it because I'm not here to do a sales
pitch for the company but the the two
products together licensing for the next
3 years will cost the community college
system about
$150,000 probably the more important
piece is that somebody actually has to
manage the work of this and probably
looking at an additional 125,000 of
expense for the staff work surrounding
this so all in somewhere in the
$175,000 a year for the Community
College systems efforts that doesn't
account for every bit of time on each of
the campuses where faculty are working
on course equivalencies and the under
lying material that will feed the system
it's really more the administrative
support for the system and how does that
work with a university system with Keen
or Plymouth or UNH so so keen and
Plymouth are not so UNH is piloting
tests now the there's another product as
as the chancellor um U just stated UNH
is thinking about that understanding the
the importance of the um of the tool but
again it doesn't come without cost and
uh so I would estimate the university
system would incur similar costs that
the that Mark has just mentioned it's
it's the people it's keeping it up to
it's the
implementation working across all the
institutions um The Faculty will need to
be involved to because it will be when
curriculum is updated that will need to
be included in the in the
database so I I would yes across the two
systems we're probably looking at a half
a million dollars when you talk about
the licensing the people the the
um technology maybe an implementation
partner that will need to help stand
this up on on seven campuses and three
campuses so it's it it's not without
cost
for repres Mr
Appleby thank you no no
representative a quick question um
understanding the costs to implement
this do you have any idea what the costs
are with the current system where oneoff
people apply they come from White
Mountain they want to go to Plymouth
someone has to analyze their Trend I'm
currently right now we're managing this
primarily with the resources that are
part of our enterprise system and that
covers a much broader range of functions
than just this so I don't have a good
way of breaking out a a specific cost
associated with it I I would say that
what we currently have isn't sufficient
and unlikely to be as effective as what
we think we're moving toward and in that
regard the cost is really lost
students so then if if we if you receive
like $550,000 or so would that be offset
by the students now knowing my path way
I've selected I can continue it and not
worry about losing the money that I've
spent right now and having things not
transfer uh I'm is is the allocation or
appropriation of another half a million
do offset by the the positive outcome we
have from students oh would say
absolutely be I can't I'm not going to
sign in blood that that's the case but
if it's if it's difficult to to engage
if if it's difficult for a
student they're not as apt to
to enroll transfer and enroll in the
programs if it's easy I would think
there would be many more students taking
advantage of it can I I'm going to back
up just for a minute we um so the
university system accepts all
credits right there it's not that
credits aren't accepted it's that if you
need credits certain credits for a
major if those credits don't apply for
the courses that you need for the major
okay if you take these courses in the
community college system they're all
going to transfer into the courses you
need for this program that that you want
to continue at the four-year level does
that make
sense okay if I may representative luno
earlier asked it use the phrase open
admission for for many of our programs
and as community colleges we are in fact
open admission if you've satisfied High
School completion highet GED you're
eligible for admission to our college
and to most of our programs but we do
have some that are competitive and have
specific prerequisites where student
needs to demonstrate capability in math
science whatever it might happen to
be in in some respects this discussion
about trans transferability has a
similar U split for a lot of students
who are not sure what they want to study
a lot of the courses they're likely to
take will satisfy general education
requirements or elective requirements
but if they're pursuing some of the more
structured and competitive programs in
engineering technology and healthc Care
in addition to having perhaps fewer
electives associated with them it's
often the case that math is critical
that a student has to begin with a
certain level of math and so a student
who's unsure what they're going to study
and takes math courses that are not you
know below the level of calculus for
instance and perhaps then takes a
Physics course that's algebra based
rather than calculus based may have to
continue to make up those credits take
those courses so the majority of
students who are in our more accessible
programs probably don't lose a lot of
credits in this process particularly if
the programs they eventually find their
way toward are more in Liberal Arts or
business where the structure of the
curriculum often lends itself to a
little bit more breath and flexibility
but for students interested in health
care technology science programs that
have some of those underlying structural
requirements and this is where we'll
we'll be helpful for students to see
where they need to start uh for a
student who's still genuinely undecided
and is not prepared to take that more
rigorous Math course you know again this
may not resolve that problem but for
students who know that this is their
aspiration they will have Clarity that
this is where they need to start the
journey is that rigorous Math course
being taught at the community college
system level or do they have to wait and
take that elsewhere no that that is
taught at the community colleges uh no
no no difficulty accessing High highly
demanding curriculum for our students
but again it becomes a question does the
student understand that that's what the
need is and by having these Pathways
mapped out for a student who aspires to
an engineering degree to know that an
abet accredited engineering program at
UNH requires calculus as the
foundation again that's very helpful
guidance early on for a student and and
this approach will be helpful for
students to find that sign early rather
than just fortuitously have a
conversation with an
advisor thank are there any other
questions on this number one we have you
know Ju Just A clarifying um thing thank
you Mr chair so just on that on that
point though where where you have sort
of some underlying structural um um
skills uh to
to on the part on the part of the
student to uh to even to enter some of
these programs at the community college
level uh once they've once they've
demonstrated that they've met that um
that either through the work they've
done in high school or an application
that you know uh you know at the
community college level or work they do
at Community College uh once they've
successfully completed the program or
the pathway at the community college
it's then seamless getting into the
university system so so that that
guarantee of of
structural skill is done at the
community college level and not
corre correct but I want to clarify the
student who has taken our calculus
courses has satisfied the requirements
for the calculus courses there are still
competitive programs within the
university system I'd defer to
Chancellor preventure to clarify whether
uh completing the courses do would mean
you wouldn't have to repeat the courses
but I don't want to say that we've reach
a point where every program is uniformly
accessible through Pathways because some
still have competive access okay okay
the the Paul the Paul col Paul College
business school is the most competitive
nursing's number two and engineering's
number
three I I would add one other point
about the transfer system and the
technology that we're looking at we've
focused exclusively in this conversation
about coures part of what we ultimately
want to be able to do I apologize the
speakers is poorly position here for eye
contact part of what we'd like to be
able to do is that there are industry
recognized credentials there's training
that employers provide that students can
demonstrate competency some of that
aligns with courses that we offer and if
a student can demonstrate that
competency and we can document that as
college level learning appropriate to
the discipline with the right learning
outcomes we also don't want the student
have to repeat that as a classroom
exercise if in fact they've already
mastered it for reasons of time and cost
but also
you many students come directly from
high school into college and for many of
us that was a typical pathway but
majority of our students are part-time
students and uh not a majority but
plurality of them are older students and
often they're piecing together education
we would like students who may have
missed the opportunity right after high
school to go to college and worried that
they weren't capable students who have
mastered some of these competencies
through employment whether it's through
military service or with Employers in
industry or Healthcare wherever the
setting we want them to recognize that
that's college level learning they've
demonstrated success they are capable of
doing it we think that this is also
something that encourages people whose
paths are somewhat different in reaching
higher education postsecondary education
to know that they have the opportunity
but more importantly they have the
capability when they may be left High
School believing that they didn't we'll
be able we'll talk a little bit more of
that when we get to item number three
where we're talking about workplace and
recognize
credentials uh in Industry credentials
that may contribute to uh this whole
process let's go on to number two right
now the emissions process streamlining
acceptance processes to proactively
accept students um uh uh based on GPA
and all that that's number two do you
want to speak to that I know we've sort
bit so on the
University system side to the from the
community college system what we're
talking about right now with our
counterparts in the University system is
something called direct admission that
students who fulfill the requirements
complete the associate degree following
these Pathways would be directly
admitted into the university system in
the vast majority of the usnh programs
without the additional burden of an
application fee and with a streamlined
application process that in some ways is
almost more of a notification of I'm on
my way so no uncertainty about whether
the student would be admissible having
satisfied the requirements for the
associate degree as part of the pathway
for the community college system we're
also looking at whether there's an
opportunity for us to make New
Hampshire's high school students more
broadly aware of the opportunities for
the University system or the community
college system we understand from
discussions with director applebe and
others that there are some impediments
to the ways in which we can communicate
with high school students and the ways
in which the Department of Education can
make information available or or to to
those students and that may require some
legislative attention uh to to address
our ability to reach that broader
audience we certainly have access to
information about the roughly 6,000
seniors in a given year who are taking
Early College courses or the roughly
10,000 students a year who take Early
College courses who may be seniors or
Juniors we can reach that group but we
can't necessarily reach the other 5 to
6,000 High School seniors in each cohort
who who may also benefit from knowing
about opportunities that are available
to them what are some of those
impediments that you speak of is it
or second yes
um understanding that data isn't my
division that's Caitlyn
but my understanding is there's a lot of
data we don't collect we're not allowed
to collect on individual students in our
K12 system so to provide a list to let's
say the community college or university
system um of all of the Juniors right
now enrolled in a public high school in
the state we're not we don't collect a
lot of that data and more important and
we can't share what we do collect so I
think what what we'd love to do is uh
send a text or an email or phone call to
every
graduating senior in in the state that
maybe that's but but you know that data
is hard to come by that you know if you
met there certain eligibility you're
admitted to the community college system
or the university system
automatically and I believe the direct
admit correct me if I'm wrong Mark um
between the community college system and
the university
system even if a student graduate from
the community college system outside of
one of these Pathways and met certain
GPA um
levels we'd like to direct admit those
students as well they may have to we
talked about this already with the
credits but at least give those students
an option if they were interested in in
continuing on with their with their
education but again we have we have
data in order to text every high school
graduate in the state we need all their
phone numbers or email or addresses that
we could send them a postcard with a QR
code on it you know it's you're you're
directly admitted but that's personal
wow yeah for example um one of the
articles I left with the chair this
morning speaking about Georgia and the
success Georgia has seen with direct
admission notes that one of the Georgia
programs at the state level collects all
the contact information for high
schoolers which then they make available
to their their state systems for the
direct one you know one of the benefits
of having that data is they can work
with their systems to make that data
available so I I I believe it's in the
Georgia article um that I left on your
desk but you know that's a practical
limitation to effectively doing direct
admission yes we could deliver a box of
postcards to every guidance counselor in
the state but it's certainly far more
effective if every if every student gets
a text
or some type of direct Outreach personto
person then the guidance office has a
stack of postcards and they give them
out we've given the College Board the
authority to communicate with folks
parents about the SAT scores and results
directly could that same thing be done
by the department to to the higher
education systems so that we can have
this you know direct admittance and sped
up and and so that you've graduated from
high school you're you're now accepted
to PSU yeah I think that would be a good
question for Caitlyn so I can certainly
ask her when I see
her you know what we could do there and
if we needed statutory Assistance or I'm
not even sure how much we actually
collect at the department I don't think
this yeah sounded right I'm with you I I
just don't understand you know we've
missed the boat
here just go ahead um this narrative
that has gone on for quite a period of
time uh we we've been hearing this
narrative I have for the last 30
years 30 years Walter pet and I headed a
task force about transferability and
acceptance 30 years ago and we thought
we solved the problem 30 years ago
evidently it's not only uh
resurfaced but it now has
expanded and and we're trying to deal
with it with different uh different
methodologies but it it seems to me if
basic data is not
available we're we're we're sort of
fighting a game that we can't win and
our our goal is to
provide the best opportunity for our
students and I want to compliment the
Community College my grandson is a
student at the University of Utah He's a
freshman he got nine credits accepted
that he took at portzman high school
under the under the program they
accepted the credits I I don't know what
category they put them but they accepted
the credits so that's a plus Forest I'm
going to bring good news to the to the
occasion today that they they were
accepted was it going to save my my
daughter and her husband money I don't
think so but indeed the credits got
accepted I I think the thing that that I
look at is basic fundamentals if basic
knowledge is not available for us for
example knowledge about each one of our
our graduates how how are we going to
assist them as as they move as they move
forward and you know we talked about
direct that that's that's I think that's
the that's the first question I want
address if that's not available how do
we how do we positively affect these
these people these students because we
want them to move on to move on to the
Community College if that's the the path
that they want to take to the university
system if that's the path that they that
they want to take but you know
connectability is problematic in the old
days the old days we had the title 3
Program which financed Admissions and
admissions councils would go out to
every High School in the state and
gather information it seemed to work now
the title 3 program is good that that
initiative is good but as a result
there's a g it seems to me there's a gap
Mr CH and if we kit fill the Gap how we
going to service the
kids thank you
if if I may say and I appreciate and
what I said roughly 25 years ago was in
the context of the work that you and
Governor Peterson worked on at the time
he was serving as a trustee of both
systems and and pointed to this issue I
would tell you we've made significant
progress over time that we're we're
getting much further along than we were
in the early days part of the issue was
accreditation the accreditation the
Community College systems not aligned
with the accreditation of the University
system which became a barrier there have
been some additional layers of of
specialized accreditation whether it was
aacs aacsb for business programs or AET
accredit much of that has been resolved
where we really are right now is gaps in
information that we're trying to fix
rather than resistance on the part of
the University system instances where a
student doesn't know what courses will
or won't transfer and may again as an
undecided student may start with a math
course that does not align with the abet
required calculus based course so I
think we've made some progress for years
the College Board has allowed colleges
to purchase contact information for sat
takers the problem for us the limitation
is that that only allows us to purchase
the contact information for students who
take the SAT but not for every student
who has the potential to be successful
generally speaking community colleges
don't require the SAT and for a lot of
students who have not taken the
SAT they're in a place where we don't
have access to them we don't know how to
reach them other than through the
schools and again those who've
participated in our early college it
gives us some entree but we're really
talking about and I think it's part of
the Statewide need for the future if
we're going to be successful with what
are declining demographics an aging
Workforce the need for succession in
every industry that we have plus filling
the needs of new industries that we have
we can't waste Talent so the ability to
find those students who have aptitude
but don't know it have aptitude but
don't have confidence have potential but
are worried that cost is going to be a
barrier we've got to find ways to reach
them and this is what we're trying to
find is is there a way through direct
admission with cooperation support from
Department of Education enabled by
families represent Mooney oh did you
have a
followup I mean I I concur with
everything you're saying obviously but
the question is doing it getting it
getting it done and this has
been for me it's it's like a lifelong
process and I'm at the end of that
lifespan you know I'm believe in town
and I don't know how much I've
accomplished in in the 50 years I've
been in public life I I I really wor I
worry about it and and now I have
grandchildren who are going through the
process and luckily their parents are
very keen both College graab you know
and so forth so on so they they have a
path but I I worry about I worry about
the kids at Manchester High School West
where we have a 60% High School
graduation rate where we have a minority
scho I've got eight minority schools in
my district how do we address this
situation these kids the treny rate is
very high I can understand why you can't
get data they don't show up at
school it I mean these are social
problems that are occurring in the
environment that I've represented for a
long period of time and these are things
that have to be addressed for all of the
things you just mentioned the workforce
I mean what are we going to do if we
don't if we don't
don't get these get these things done
the workforce is disappearing the
workforce is
aging the the new era is requires more
knowledge more technology what what
we're bringing into Manchester now
requires a high level of
Education all right we've got we've got
a a birging industry this
this you know the C and his crew I
talked to need he needs a th000 people
he needs well educated people we gave
him money to pay bonuses to bring these
people we we'll try to do a lot of
things but we've got to get to that base
and and I I really worry about that I
really thank thank you thank
you Chancellor provent will indul me a
little bit more I I will say we share
that I I would tell you that I genuinely
believe we're making progress and we've
made progress because you and others who
share this interest have pushed us and
have worked to make sure that we create
these opportunities we've gotten better
over time we still have work to do and
part of this is the needs of the state
for a Workforce part of this is equity
we're either going to bring everybody
with us or we're going to leave some
folks behind and that ultimately is
going to create more challenges for the
state if students coming out of K
through 12 can be literate andn numerate
and love learning that's going to be
critical because they're going to have
to learn throughout their lives we note
consistently that the work life of 50 or
60 years after high school is going to
require students to
continuously understand changing
technology changing Industries in this
state and being prepared to make the
kinds of transitions in their lives that
that are important to them I I've
remarked in other
settings we offer an associate degree in
nursing one in five of our students in
our nursing program already holds a
bachelor's degree in some other field
but found out later in life that what
they needed to be doing was to become a
nurse so we need to prepare for students
over the course of a 50 or 60 year work
life are going to make those transitions
it starts with having students with the
fundamental building blocks of of the
ability to learn and the passion for
Learning and what we're working on are
putting in some of the structures that
will support that I I would say that
when we start talking about the
technology platforms direct admission
we're we're starting to operationalize
what have been aspirations we're
starting to make more concrete how the
work actually gets done rather than just
good intentions and I do think it's
tangible
progress thank you I'd like to have
represent Mooney uh you had a a point
you wanted to mention uh then I'd like
to get on to number three
here thank you Mr chairman and thank you
both for being here I can understand the
preference to have direct contact with
high school students but I feel like I
have to interject the role of the
guidance counselor and uh hear why
that's unsatisfactory in terms of a
preference is it because they're too
much is expected of them these days
they're dealing with all sorts of things
other than guiding careers and college
choices or perhaps something else thank
you I I think representative um you
you've hit it right on the head that
that guidance counselors with with um
mental health issues behavioral health
issues in the schools the the supports
that students need now that maybe they
didn't need 20 years ago our guidance
counselors are spending a lot more time
supporting students in that in that way
and and I don't I'm painting a broad
brush but then maybe they did again 20
years ago with career advising so to put
that another here's another thing for
you to do guidance counselors make sure
everybody gets one of these cards um I I
think is well and I will I will also say
from
a uh maybe marketing is not the right
term but to get communication from the
community college system or the
university system
congratulations you're accepted and
there are so many options for you in our
state to further your education you know
call here or text here for more
information is is you know maybe
beneficial for those students and put a
little wind in their
sales I concur with you on that direct
communication to that family to that
student to the parents
congratulations you've accomplish that
rather than having to go through that
third party I think there's really a
benefit to what we're trying to address
here and I think this is something the
legislature needs to look at in terms of
you're having access to that data that
you need in order to facilitate this
activity of Direct Communications with
the student and maybe we need to work
with you Steve on that one yeah I have
reached out to director Davis um
regarding the data piece so more to come
on that and I just want also
representative Moody brought up a great
point because we talked about this
during the task force meeting that
guidance counselors what we all grew up
with don't exist anymore they're school
counselors first of all uh a national
study was just completed in the last
several months that showed that on
average a school counselor or guidance
counselor depending on the state spends
in excess of 80% of their time on mental
health
issues which conversely means 20% or
less on guidance and and postsecondary
Futures so I think and there's been a
movement at the national level one of my
programs representing money is uh
licensing K12 Educators including school
counselors and there's been a real
movement at the national level
over the last few decades to reposition
counselors more in the mental health
side than in the guidance so the
national standards have even shifted and
I think that's in recognition of what's
happening in the schools so uh and
during our task force meetings we um
took some some information from granted
Advance because they do a lot of
Outreach in the schools and
unfortunately relying on another entity
to come in and do that counseling
because the schools can't get can't get
to it um so we we brought them in and
they were uh quite helpful with some of
their
information so thank
you just real quick Mr chair thanks so
um I recall a few years ago this
committee um worked on a bill and I
don't recall the bill number but uh but
I think it modified it amended RSA
193c colon 12 and it was direct to um to
the department and reading from the the
statute the department May collect and
the district shall provide student
address information uh from the
individual school districts and uh and
it and it does say solely for the
purpose of effectuating the distribution
of assessment results and comparative
data is provided in this section but it
goes on to say the report shall be
provided to parents in an informative
and instructional manner to help
children meet challenging State academic
standards and advanced student learning
and I was wondering how is the
department um I guess
um utilizing this um this relatively new
section of law that came into effect on
um 20 in
2021 that that was put I remember doing
that and it was for the purpose of
having the results of the SAT by the uh
which the College Board had to direct
mail that to the address of the student
right rather than to the school to
facilitate timeliness um my my question
would be why can't we do the same thing
for the Department to you know get this
information so they can be sending that
congratulations hello you now have
earned this um I think it we go along
way let's go on to number three here and
we'll get back to this you know with
some of our concluding remarks but
number three deals with the basically
credentials it in it includes those as
well as traditional courses we have a
platform that we'll be implementing that
allows us to capture all of that and
again for working adults in particular
those with military service where the
government has made significant
investments in their Education and
Training the opportunity to incorporate
that into the structure of a degree or
certific program is time sensible cost
effective and again for those those
adult Learners who did not necessarily
meet great success in high school and
are not confident of their potential to
realize that that is in fact success
with college level learning we we think
it's an encouraging uh way of helping
students recognize that I don't have a
long road in front of me to complete a
degree in fact I've already got the
foundation for a degree or certificate
based on what I've already accomplished
and by helping students see those
shorter paths those clearer paths that
are built on a foundation of their own
success we think that that helps bring
more people into the workforce more
people into opportunity so in your
report here you talk about the Nashville
Community College uh having using tests
to facilitate this how's that program
working there so that that's still in
the pilot stage U they're working with
college for professional studies at unh
was the the nucleus the old granted
State College and I've recently met with
Dean Dell and uh I think uh one two of
his colleagues who are instrumental in
that partnership with nashille about
extending that across all seven of our
colleges so although still in the pilot
stage as we begin to implement we think
we can grow that relatively
quickly any other questions on that's
the University of Maryland when I was in
the service in the 70s was giving credit
for things I had taken biological you
know studies which I had done with the
chemical core and others I was getting
credit for that stuff even for physical
education um so there's nothing new
about
this there's nothing new about this part
of it is our Collective recognition that
the learning outcomes that can be
documented actually align in many cases
with curriculum that we offer if there's
a a way for us to capture that
information document it appropriately
and incorporate it into degrees I I
cited CPS former of Granton State
College under their accreditation with
New England Commission on higher
education up to 60 credits toward a
bachelor's degree could come from pla
this workplace based or experiential
learning that's appropriately documented
and although I don't know that all of
our institutions will move to that level
of of uh acceptance of pla I I think we
can make significant progress in helping
students find onramps into our programs
particularly from some of our own
certificate programs our boot camps you
may be familiar with a microelectronics
boot camp program that Nashville has
worked on in partnership with BAE
systems since 2017 over 300 graduates
foundational learning that can flow into
technology or management degrees that
allow for career progression and and
career longevity uh so again not just
things people bring from the outside but
some of our own uh short-term training
programs that give people more immediate
access to skills that are in demand in
the workforce but then serve as the
foundation for growth over time thank
you anything else in item number three
here okay number four is one that I've
had some discussions with you uh last
week even on uh Early College dual
enrollment where are we going with this
this a program for everybody that we've
been allocating dollars yeah
appropriating what 3 million two two two
and a half two and a half I know the
request was for three and a quarter but
um so for the purpose of early college
and and um a lot of good things are
happening there you know and can you
just give us an overview of this uh I
think that one of the things we wanted
to do is capture more students that are
leaving our state and going College
elsewhere I see this as a key to
capturing them early on when they're in
high school um I I do too sir we we have
data we looked at students who
participated in our Early College
Programs between 2016 and 2022 and the
reason we stopped at that point was just
to be able to see what happened for the
more recent High School completers in
the years that followed of that group
83% went on to post secondary education
out of that roughly 35,000 students we
had over 28,000 who went to college of
that
group about 80% went to four-year
institutions rather than 2-year
institutions and 55% left the state to
do that about 11,000 stayed in New
Hampshire again started with 35,000
students about 28,000 went to
postsecondary education 11,000 went went
to fouryear institutions in New
Hampshire and of that group 6,600 ended
up in the University system during that
period of time about 6,000 of those
students ended up with a community
college system what what that tells us
is that students who are currently
participating in early college courses
Early College opportunities are are
probably already the students who know
and anticipate that they're going to
college and based on their preference
for fouryear institutions their
preference for out of State we know that
this is a group of students who may
already have certain advantages if we're
going to expand opportunity and also do
more to keep these students in New
Hampshire what we need to be able to do
is build capacity not just make this
available to top tiers of students but
make this Avail to a wider group of
students who have potential but may not
have quite as much access to these these
high uh more challenging opportunities
schools without getting into the
mechanics of how we would propose to do
that what I would tell you is that if we
can make this work with House Bill 1530
tie these to the courses that are part
of the pathways that help students find
their way from the community college
system to the university system we can
increase the likelihood that these
students when they're ready to enroll in
college will stay in state will stay if
not the community college system and the
university system because they've
already got a foundation and it's not
just the courses but if we use the
opportunity while these students are
taking these courses to introduce them
to our campuses ours and the University
Systems so that the students recognize
the opportunities connect with our
faculty see our facilities I think we
can begin to bend this curve that has
had so many students leaving the state
the other piece that's just the most
fundamental part of this is the cost
piece of this the state's investment
about $2.5 million in each year of the
current
bium the return on value if the students
enrolled to let to say this differently
students took over 54,000 credits
through Early College this past year at
our current rate of
$215 per credit plus a a registration
fee of $25 per credit those students at
our rate saved over $10 million they and
their families if they went to the
university syst on a per credit basis
rather than paying for a semester you're
you're almost talking double that amount
so the the savings to families is
measurable but the problem and Senator
delandro touched on this with his
grandson University of Utah nine credits
may not materialize to much savings
because instead of taking this course
you take that course but you still have
four years of college to complete but if
we can help students complete a semester
or a year of college level learning
without the cost associated with it not
only are we saving them a year of
tuition and perhaps room and board at a
residential campus but we're giving them
the opportunity if they're motivated
either to pursue a master's degree or or
to get into the workforce a year earlier
now for our students who tend to be
part-time students it's a little bit
more difficult to to say oh it's going
to save them a year but in it maybe more
importantly for our students who are
often taking one or two courses at a
time the more Foundation we can give
them while they're still in high school
when can take these opportunities
perhaps in larger strides we're saving
them significant time on the other end
and again if we tie these courses not
just to our degree programs but
incorporate industry recognized
credentials help them be better prepared
to hit the workforce in in demand with
skills that employers value we we give
them a lot of advantages that again
strengthen the the workforce by bringing
talent and potential to the four not
any questions on that
one
um we have this program available now to
students that are in grades 10 11 and
12 and we allocated 2.5 million per year
bium due to the level of
funding is it possible for a student to
take the the maximum of four courses or
how's that working out now in terms of
the student who's really challenging
this thing and would like to do you know
take more than is there a limit have we
C it or something on a practical level
we've said to students we can offer two
courses with this scholarship because
otherwise we run the risk of exhausting
the funds without equitably allocating
the opportunity for students and
families who have their own resources
and want to uh increment that they
certainly can do that but we don't
currently have adequate funding to be
able to make this available for up to
four courses as as written in statute a
a as we've discussed I I do think that
there are different models that we could
look at for how we could make this more
widely available that would
be cost effective for the state sensible
for us more importantly and value for
students and families uh but again did
not want to necessarily go into the to
the Weeds on that because there's a lot
of a lot of detail that could become
confusing without some handouts and some
some charts and graphs just to make it
that much more confusing so I I I I I
won't go down the weeds either but uh in
terms of a student now that's being
restricted to two
courses uh uh and statute says you can
take up the four and Beyond four it's on
you the student um now if the student
once takes three or four is that on the
student or according to statute it
shouldn't be how are you getting around
this we we we've explained that what we
have our resources for two and I I would
defer to director Doran who's with me
today if we have examples where any body
has pushed back I think generally
speaking people have appreciated that
the state has made an investment that
it's it's finite and and that we are
trying to be evenhanded in in allocating
but no no one's pushed back on that and
I think when we interpreted the language
we looked at it as students could take
up to four if that funding was available
but it's not I mean with only not only
but 2.5 were very very appreciative that
but that doesn't allow us to offer four
student four courses per student it only
allows us to offer
two yeah I can remember that
discussion any other further questions
on the running Start program or dual
concurrent sure yeah so um if I was to
um if I was a family looking for
opportunities for um uh for my sophomore
junior senior in uh in high school
school and U and and uh just to find out
you know what opportunities were there
particular particularly in programs like
running start that I can take um you
know as a high school student and uh and
get college credit where would I um
where would where would a where would a
parent or a student go to find that
information wouldn't you go to the
counselor in your
which
website
okay school programs and parent can
click right on that see all the Early
College we changed the the terminology
of running right to Early College all
under the Early College umbrella we have
Early College in high school early
college online and early college at your
campus or on campus so student those
three programs are very clearly defined
and our website but also our early
college coordinators visit all the high
schools right now they're out there
canvasing all the high schools in the
courses where we offer in high schools
where we offer these courses and they're
handing out flyers and giving all the
information hopefully it makes it home
to parents um not always so that's why
we try to have information on our
website and also looking at some other
marketing strategies to get out to
parents uh Beth I have a question for
you just ear
College available through VX and is the
funding for that come through VX or
through the $2.5 million appropriated to
the community college system great
question we have a partnership with VX
for our Early College online program
because that program is taught by our
own faculty so the cost is higher than
our early college in the high school we
obviously don't pay the high school
teachers for the early college and high
school program so the Early College
online program has a higher cost much
like our Early College on campus program
does so we receive $150 from the
scholarship for Early College online we
also receive $175 from daac for every
enrollment so that total revenue for us
is
$325 for a Early College online course
versus an early college on campus is
about $350 or so thank you yeah yeah
thank thanks Mr shair I'm just um I'm
I'm surprised that the uh that the New
Hampshire Department of Education
website doesn't um doesn't provide any
links to this information as it does
provide links um to the education
Freedom account program with a direct
link to the children's scholarship fund
a direct link to tutor.com information
on the learn everywhere program these
are in the very very first um items on
the homepage of the New Hampshire
Department of Education links to Lexia
letters which I think um never ever
passed this committee um links to um uh
College and Career Readiness that does
not contain the information that you
were just talking about Beth um and then
um and then links to um to I think oped
pieces written by the commissioner that
uh that are titled like thank God
someone is looking out for our children
and we have not served our children well
an education choice save Public Schools
I'm really surprised that our New
Hampshire education department doesn't
provide links that actually would serve
our students and in particular provide
them with information about early
college and um and um leverage the um
the
outstanding um um State schools both
Community College and the university
system so that's just a comment
Mr chair it could be also a
recommendation that we put forward from
the committee I'd love to turn yeah
yeah okay um any any others on the Early
College side things because we still
have a couple areas here which kind of
intriguing the next one coming up is
number five uh and that's to the
university system and we're talking now
of what's going on at Plymouth State
University in terms of their application
for the three-year bachelor's degree you
want to take this one y
State this month late last month no
we're in October sorry in September um
submitted to Nei which is the New
England accrediting body um proposals
for five programs for um bachelor's
degrees at less than 120 credits so uh
you could complete a 96 credit degree in
in three years and there are five
programs criminal justice robotics cyber
security I'm not going to remember the
other two you have uh police studies
business administration applied robotics
cyber security and Outdoor Adventure
leadership correct so believe Nei met
last week and we're waiting for final
word on whether or not the the programs
have been approved you I will have the
answer for you by the November
1st report so th that's done under an
Innovations um initiative through nii
there are still a lot of questions that
uh nii Commissioners are asking and
answering relative to you know currently
if you once you receive a bachelor's
degree you're no longer palale eligible
so if a
student received um a bachelor's degree
for less than 120 credits
and then wanted to continue on to a 120
credit bachelor degree right now under
Federal pel rules that student would not
be eligible to get a fourth year
bachelor degree if that makes sense so
there are lots of questions but other
programs I think Marat College may have
had a a program or two that was approved
earlier so we're moving in this
direction um and and nii has been
supportive to
date now at the trustee meeting I had
attended was it last week or the week
before I came there everything's couple
weeks ago couple weeks ago there is
question about Nei and I know that the
president of keing state is on that
board um but is the staff at Plymouth
State according to the president of PSU
was very involved in making these
recommendations in fact supported by the
folks that professional professors and
all at Plymouth State then why do we if
they see a program that they like to why
then does it have to be approved by a
time delay when it was the application
was sent in in what August
15th and here we are now going into
October and November before Nei gets
around saying that's good idea well
again the um I'm not here to defend Nei
but the the me meeting that was held
last week the ne's meeting was probably
the first meeting it had since Plymouth
submitted its proposal so we should have
an answer
shortly I so I I don't I don't know that
the the timing is off I I spoke with Don
yesterday president Burks yesterday
about this and um if approved they're
going to be ready to stand these up next
fall that's good any other questions on
this one
by doing this are they saying you don't
need some of that general education you
need these specific things related to
cyber security or or in the other four
topics so is that how they're cutting
back and certainly making it more
affordable I would say if the
committee happy to have um provos Bo
bodic come down like their faculty were
definitely involved with the
Provost happy to have them come down at
a at a future meeting of the and talk
about because again this is happening
around the country so happy to have them
come down and talk about the come down
some and and talk to us about
that uh going on then to number six
here and this is one that is is
hopefully going to save some dollars
here uh shared location of
administrative
offices um yes we're both um
systems have been working we would
expect that we'll be a the university
system will be able to move into a
building on the nhti campus by May June
at the latest we are in the design phase
um value engineering or value
engineering that's code for getting the
cost down um and a building on the
campus was identified that um it needs
some work so we're
sharing in the cost of the there's
deferred maintenance but um anyway so
yes we would expect that we'll be in the
building by um late spring early summer
it will save the university system about
$250,000 a year in rent and we will
provide um you know a rental income
stream to the community college system
and then I'll be right in Mark's back
backyard
literally literally so you really talk
farum Hall which is the building right
behind
yours that's a good move because we're
going to save save money there by taking
them from down the other side of conquer
here was it Chanel not Chanel yeah yeah
Chanel
drive any questions regarding that it's
I think that's a real positive stroke
going forward
and the item number seven which you had
here in the report to us is dealing with
unified
accreditation work work in progress
we're currently engaging with the
national Center for higher education
Management Systems which is a group
that's been working across the country
for the last 50 years very data oriented
policy and strategy oriented uh they've
been Gathering both our internal data as
well as labor market data other data
from from federal and and other sources
they're going to be here in New
Hampshire across the state visiting
stakeholders on our campuses well as
legislators other other stakeholders
throughout New Hampshire week of October
1st 21st to the 25th and we expect
recommendations I should say a set of
alternatives for the board Board of
Trustees consideration perhaps some
recommendations among those Alternatives
by late January early February our board
will have an opportunity to consider
those later the ne next spring and and
may take may choose to take action in
the coming year whether the decision is
to move towards single accreditation as
a a Statewide singly accredited
institution um is an open question but
we're continuing to work on
administrative redesign ways in which
seven colleges can work better together
for if efficiencies primarily to be able
to reinvest in things that we know we
need to be able to do but also to create
more seamless experiences for students
so they don't have to learn to be a
student at multiple campuses that do
things different ways so would expect to
have more concrete information on this
one sometime in the in the
committee not see any there uh last
number eight that you had down in this
report of areas that you're working
towards Implement a common enterprise
resource planning Erp
platform so the university system has
been oh we're 18 to 24 months into
implementation of a new Erp
Enterprise res resource plan it's all of
HR all of Finance all of student and
we're going
Live December 21st with with HR and
finance this is a multi-year TENS of
millions of dollars project our old
Erp was 30 years old it's
um what we're what we currently are
using is highly inefficient we probably
have 75
bolt-on pieces of Technology on that Erp
so we're going to
workday um the student part of workday
again across our institutions each
institution has its own student system
we're going to
one workday student system go live is
27 I cannot overstate the amount of
work the investment something like this
requires so um it would be terrific for
the two systems to be on the same
platform but again I cannot it's it's a
enormous investment
um I'm I'm confident it is going to
result in enormous benefit for the
University system um but that is would
that's a heavy lift with intensive
investment in my opinion we need to
continue to work together I will say one
um even on smaller pieces of of
Technology we're I spoke with my chief
procurement officer not too long ago
when we're going to get some seats for
the Community College system in our
procurement platform so we could start
leveraging more scale um but but this is
um let me just number
eight is nowhere near the
six um so I I'll I'll leave we're
thrilled about what we're doing at the
University system but the work that has
been involved and can it
and we are
not we won't be finished with student
27 okay those are the eight topical
areas that you have you've you selected
to share with us right now are there any
other there's there's a number of
short-term objectives and
long-term can you speak to any of those
which are you know not listed here that
the task force also came up with these
um areas so yeah Mr chair yes just I I
had a quick question on the Erp okay if
we we could just do that thanks so when
did when did you say the Erp was going
to go live HR and finance yeah December
of this year okay okay
student is TW calendar 27 I believe okay
and and as far as HR and finance and and
going live
um and and I'm just asking the question
from an oversight um uh thing but but
how do you know when the um when the
live how how do well we're working up to
it right now that's
what I I guess what
um what I'm what I'm trying to get at is
is obviously it's a it's a very it's a
critical system for for the the
university system and and wanting to
make sure that that late in the year
that when you're when you're ready to
cut over live and you know all companies
do these things too in terms of making
sure of the reliability and I'm just I
just want to want to know that that's um
going on we are testing
and the the payroll is number one and
that all the tests believe me we test
and retest and retest there are hundreds
of people working on this okay fantastic
um almost Around the Clock okay so
believe me if it's not going to work
we're not going live but there are no
indications as I sit here right now that
that we won't go live on December okay
that's that's great to hear so thanks
Kathy Kathy before we we adjourn here um
I'd like to ask one other question which
is more of a short as well as long term
where are we on the issue of
affordability for students and the
efficiency of tuition
freezing uh we have Frozen the the
tuition rate
here with this shrinking
demographic and tuition being primary
source of
Revenue how how are you going to make
this thing work um and that it's an
important issue so the affordability
issue for students is huge that's why we
see them going to Utah or to Georgia or
some other place because it's probably
getting a Best Buy
um how do we address this issue of
tuition free is that going to continue
or or
the margin must be getting very very
close here as far as six years yeah yes
is it six years now yes six years this
is this is um year
six um I representative Vlad
I the board will be voting on that this
month I know
it it's it's increasingly difficult and
believe me you know representative lad
um
we
are there's a lot of work going on to
contain costs and as inflation has has
been at high levels over the past five
or six years we have kept tuition flat
um at the same time need increases
Financial need
increases which puts more pressure on
the bottom line we've done a lot to
contain costs
but at some point um we our board and
our presidents are not going to run in
the red as a system that's not prudent
um for the the future health of our
University system so
um I don't know what will happen next
academic year but the it the pressure is
mounting um as our margins
slim so are we going to follow the lead
of Vermont where 80% of their kids are
out of state students and where we here
is that where we're going to seek
further revenue from out ofate students
well all New Hampshire students who are
eligible which
are many are accepted to the university
and Plymouth and
Keane so
um as you said at the beginning of the
meeting that in a Wall Street Journal
article that you recently read that this
is not a New Hampshire issue it's New
England students are leaving New England
for for higher
education um so I that's why we have to
continue to provide a lot of
opportunities frankly I think we need to
collectively as
a market them better and maybe think of
a system of public
education not public higher
education you Senator when you Senator
deler when you talk about the the
students in man I still think the the
our opportunities here as our
demographics decline are those students
who never even have a twinkle in their
eye that they can go to college whether
it be Community College or any in any
way further their education but how do
we get to those students and I don't
think we can wait until high
school but then we have to think of
the system of Education right so anyway
I'm sorry I just went off on so correct
me if I'm wrong but I can remember I
thought Melinda was saying that first
generation students at Keen is higher
now than it's ever been Plymouth also
Plymouth so how do we replicate that
model throughout the whole system well
part of that is granted
guarantee um and that is another
question that you know how long can we
sustain granted
guarantee so you know if your pel
eligible in Hampshire resident you have
free
tuition
funded from from the University system
so these are these are all the the
um pressures and opportunities we need
future is there any any other other
questions
are sounds like the university and
community colleges are trying to chew
and walk at the same
time talk we can chew and walk at the
same time Mr
chair but it's uh yes represent Mooney
thank you Mr chairman and thank you both
for being here you've done a tremendous
job and I know the goal is to make this
seamless in terms of transferring
credits and doing everything you can
internally and you have a real good
grasp on that but I have to ask about
things that you can't control that are
necessary to make this work for example
internships externships clinicals hours
matching up students finding
availability there hasn't been any
mention of that today as far as I know
and my question to you is how is that
going are there any glitches there are
there any holdups there to make this
work are there any adjustments that
needed to be made there thank you
so so representative Mooney I think
that's a you could have another whole
meeting on internships apprenticeships
externships both at the community
college system and at the University
system as far as I know we're not that
that wasn't a topic for the task force
even though I know there's tremendous
work happening in both systems we know
um there are more internship
opportunities than there are students
students and we also know that students
who participate in at the University
participate in an internship from out of
if they're out of state students they're
twice as likely to stay and work here in
New Hampshire that is a huge effort
happening um the univ University of New
Hampshire invested heavily in
that I want to say maybe five or six
years ago and it's paid off but again
that's that's an investment you need to
stand that up connect businesses and and
nonprofits with students make sure that
they're having an experience
that's um you know worthy of earning
credits but that that's I think that'd
be another whole meeting on that on that
topic if I may I'd like to blend
represent Mooney's question with the
discussion representative lad was
bringing regarding tuition for community
college system also 6 years but only one
tuition increase $5 over the last 13
years so we've been effectively flat and
relative to inflation have effectively
given up about 40% of the buying power
of of the dollar during that time we've
only been able to do it because of the
state's continued investment in our work
and the reason it becomes increasingly
critical is that our program mix has
become increasingly concentrated in
areas that are abs absolutely vital for
the state our nursing programs we're
preparing over 250 graduates each year
but collectively the tuition and fees
relative to the expense of delivering
those programs those seven colleges
absorb about $3.3 million in in net cost
each year and look at our automated
manufacturing look at some Automotive
programs other technology programs those
are expensive programs to offer and as
we see less students interest in liberal
arts and business things that tend to be
more affordable to offer and in fact as
we make it more accessible through Early
College we are left with a portfolio of
programs that are vital to the state's
future but increasingly expensive to
offer and with less way of less ways of
internally
subsidizing one answer is that we
increase tuition but the risk is that we
actually create one more barrier that
causes students not to be able to pursue
those opportunities
and so trying to strike a balance that
ensures that we have adequate resources
to invest in the quality of programs
keeping them sufficiently affordable for
students to keep the demand up so that
we can produce the number of graduates
that the state needs in critical
Fields this is really delicate
choreography and I I don't know that
it's necessarily science it's a balance
of science and art and we're
continuously working on it and and the
legislature and the next Governor will
have a significant voice in our ability
to maintain this this delicate
equilibrium that we've been pursuing um
so again it's it it's vital that we not
allow the program quality to suffer by
underinvestigated
[Music]
portion of working adults the ability to
offer both access from an affordability
perspective but also convenience
regionally distributed so that they can
participate in education while they're
living their lives working raising
families and all the rest that adults do
choreography yeah it's not an easy thing
to deal with here I'm looking at what
what is the percentage that your
appropriation from the state is how much
of your revenues 60% close to 60% 60%
and you you uh
Catherine for our total budget it's
about
10% but our total
budget you know includes room uh
yeah rooms meals that's about 10%
W anything else from the higher educ
study I appreciate the reports you've
submitted to us and looks like you're
really on the road to following up what
the task force has recommended and I
certainly appreciate it and I know it's
it's a lot of work and I I've met often
with you and it's I I see what's going
on it's uh some you wonder if it's even
humanly possible but you're you're
you're doing it and I appreciate it any
other last thoughts or comments from the
committee I I have one last thought for
Senator
alesandro I I just want to say that
we've come a long long way since 30
years ago so I don't when you when you
worked with Governor Peterson so I don't
want you to leave here thinking that the
problem is still as bad as it was then
we're both both systems are very
committed to to the work going forward I
know working with the
provos and we initially were looking at
30 Pathways and now we're close to a 100
that are uniformed from the community
college up through so that is a that's a
huge taking and worked with the the
provos and professors in the in the in
the systems I I think that's really a
good step forward and u i congratulate
you on
that anything else not we're going to
anything from the the public which is
Shannon and Beth and Jen not seeing
anything thank you very much we're going
yeah okay so now get the report but you
have yeah yeah yeah but I don't have all
pages I just got I I think you got
them me did we get